the phones rang in this gaza
neighborhood saturday morning with
warnings from israeli intelligence to
evacuate
in what people say felt like only
moments
six apartment buildings were destroyed
or damaged
my four-year-old son wakes up when he
hears any sound thinking it's an air
strike and he clings to me it makes me
frustrated because my children are
scared my life has become miserable and
there is nothing left in our hands
umalik shamalik says she can't even dig
out a shirt from the rubble for her two
young sons the family is homeless but
will have to find money to pay the
mortgage on the apartment and find a new
place to live since 2008 there have been
five wars or attacks in the gaza strip
the longest was in 2014 and lasted 51
days
after the war dozens of countries met
and planned to raise five billion
dollars to rebuild gaza but not even
half that money was actually donated
the biggest donors qatar gave more than
a billion dollars in aid saudi arabia
half a billion dollars the united states
the united arab emirates and kuwait each
gave 200 million dollars
these photos show the before and after
of some reconstruction projects
after last year's israeli airstrikes
qatar and egypt committed a billion
dollars total to help gaza rebuild again
but with no time frame
gaza's ministry of public works and
housing says it needs millions of
dollars now to provide housing for 2200
families we feel that
israel is putting some obstacles
in the way of the donors they want the
reconstruction process to be slow
over the years even once reliable arab
allies have stopped offering funding and
with many humanitarian crises globally
donor fatigue has set in israel has the
occupying power they have every
responsibility
to to
to to take care of the situation there
but in a long-term run you know for for
china and also for the huge majority of
the international community what
concerns us is that we cannot simply
look at the specific
situation in a pieced piecemealed way
some in the international community may
continue to spend billions of dollars
rebuilding gaza after each war or attack
but palestinians wonder when the world
will see that it's more prudent to
invest in peace
natasha ghanim al-jazeera gaza
under international humanitarian law the
state of israel is considered an
occupying power in palestine as such
it's required to meet certain
obligations one of them is avoiding
collective punishment that means an
entire group cannot be sanctioned as
retaliation for the acts of some of its
members the confiscation or destruction
of private property is also not allowed
there is however an exception if the
occupying military force decides it's
absolutely necessary and people accused
of crimes by the occupation have a right
to a fair trial let's get some further
analysis now with jonathan kuttab who is
an international human rights lawyer and
joins us via zoom from washington dc
jonathan thanks so much for being on
this newshour
firstly is israel respecting its
obligations under international law as
an occupying power
not at all
israel has tried to carve out
a special unique status for gaza
by calling it enemy territory
in a way by taking the settlers out from
gaza
and redeploying around gaza
it pretends that international law
should not apply
that whatever problems occur in gaza are
gazan problems
at the same time it keeps to itself the
right to control
all entry points and exit points the air
above the sea next to it and the earth
below it
it is an occupying power but it does not
wish to carry out its obligations as an
occupying power at all
does israel have the right to conduct
these race raids specifically in
civilian areas to prevent what it says
is palestinians preparing to attack
well
israel like every other occupying
army uh has the right to defend its
soldiers and to defend itself now the
problem is that israel has morphed this
right of
defense of its forces
into a right to do absolutely anything
and everything it wants
under the laws of war and under the laws
of occupation there are certain
regulations for example you cannot use
collective punishment
you cannot simply destroy
things because you do not like for them
to be there
it has to be a very specific
need related directly to the security of
its forces and right now they don't have
any forces inside the territory they are
surrounding it and they are controlling
it from the air and from the ground and
from the sea so i i don't understand
exactly
the the claim of self-defense or
protection
so then what process is there to
investigate allegations of these
breaches of international humanitarian
law
there isn't uh well actually there is
the security council has the right to
intervene and to even impose sanctions
on israel
but the united states of course uses the
veto power to prevent the security
council from carrying it out its
functions
also whenever they try to investigate
israel refuses to allow access to
international bodies to enter and
investigate and when palestinians try to
go to the international criminal court
again the united states interferes and
prevents the icc from carrying it out
its functions
to the point of threatening the judges
and the prosecutors
if they would try to carry out their
duties under international law
unfortunately we have to move on but we
really do appreciate your insights and
breaking it all down for us in such a
concise way jonathan catab an
international human rights lawyer thank
you for being on this newshour
thank you
palestinian authorities are inaugurating
a street named after al jazeera
journalist shireen abu aklee who was
killed by israeli forces shireen was
shot while on assignment in janine in
the occupied west bank in may members of
the international community have
condemned her killing and continue to
call for accountability shireen was with
al jazeera for 25 years and was known as
the voice of palestine our correspondent
nida ibrahim is in ramallah in the
occupied west bank and filed this report
the legacy of shireen awakle is now
being engraved in the collective memory
of palestinians this street the shireen
abba akla street is where she used to
walk to work every day it's very close
to al jazeera's offices this is a street
used to work
to walk in and work for more than 25
years it's also very close to almanara
square a place that had had witnessed
historical events for palestinians this
is a testament to how much she's loved
we're joined here now by dr hanan
ashrawi a senior politician
what does it mean for palestinians to
have a street named after sharing
no matter how many honors
are bestowed on the
memory of shirina barclay
she is no longer a lab she's no longer
with us and she was assassinated and
deliberately killed
by an israeli sniper so sharing deserves
all this recognition
but the most important recognition is
the fact that she is held dear in the
hearts of every palestinian i think it's
very important the place of the monument
actually here because it's the place
where mostly university students pass by
here every day to see and you know most
of them are the future generation
they're going to become journalists and
she's a very significant example for
them excellent example for them not only
here in ramallah but elsewhere in the
occupied west bank we see pictures of
shireen murals being drawn by
palestinian artists
everyone here wants to send a clear
message that it's been 90 days since
sharing was killed
and her killer
hasn't been held accountable